I'll sit up front here and tell you
about my life you have to forgive me I
have a hoarse throat and I didn't want
to disappoint you so I came all the way
to be with you and to share how I did
what I did what I did
it's like show-and-tell how does a the
northa do what he does or she does and
the story about this book is very simple
one day and every year on the 4th of
July
the New York Times reproduces the
Declaration of Independence they've been
doing this as long as I can remember and
in 1999 on the 4th of July
I bought the newspaper and I looked at
it and all those red marks are things
that I did when I was doing my work and
I tried to read it it says in Congress
July 4th 1776 the unanimous declaration
of the thirteen United States of America
then I began to read it was difficult I
couldn't read them was too tiny and the
script is is small and I lost my way the
library came to my rescue and Great Neck
there's a beautiful library I went to
the library and asked the librarian to
get Mia
to help me find a copy that I could read
and she did and I took it home and I
began to read it
and I got excited I said these are the
words that made the country and I
thought when the fourth of July comes
everybody goes out and has a good time
have barbecues fireworks parades great
celebration and they take it for granted
that the country has always been here
but it hasn't it began on that day
that's the day the colony said we're
gonna break away from Britain and make
our own country and it was in
Philadelphia that they did this like a
congressional group of thirteen states
got together and on June 3rd I think it
was June June 11th they appointed five
men to go and write a Declaration of
Independence that they would send to
England and say we're out we're gonna be
our own country it's a declaration of
war really
and these men appointed Tom Jefferson
and and four others to do the writing
and they spent the whole month of June
writing and writing and writing
Jefferson was the the best write over
the group and that's why he did most of
the work but they all put their two
cents in and made corrections I think
they made 86 Corrections and finally
when they got it got it to the right
point they brought it to the Congress in
Philadelphia and presented it and that
Congress also made some Corrections so
they had to make some more Corrections
Corrections Corrections it's part of
life and finally in
on the 3rd of July it was all set and on
the 4th of July they said they published
it and said we are now declaring
ourselves independent of England so as I
read this and I repeat that this became
for me the beginning of the country and
we're all in terms of I'm I'm a child of
an immigrant everybody came from
somewhere else and they are still coming
here by droves
you saw the photograph in the paper the
other day of the Haitians who were
running away from Haiti and they their
boat got stuck and they all jumped
overboard and tried to get into this
country because it's free is free to me
you can do whatever you want so in my
world I decided because I could do
anything I want now I'm I have a lot of
years piled on my back but I'm still a
boy a child I have imagination and I
think and I thought to honor the
Declaration of Independence I will break
it up and small sentences of paragraphs
and try to make a drawing alongside it
to make the words more understandable or
easy to understand and as I began to do
this I asked friends of mine and people
who were college graduates I said when
did you ever read the Declaration of
Independence and they think about
anything night and I never read it so
the again it became strong for me to do
this because people take for granted
that the words that were written were
the words that made us begin the new
country so slowly slowly I began to try
to find illustrations that would go with
the words and the most difficult part
was to get started
when you take the the phrase when in the
course of human events I said to myself
how am I going to illustrate that and I
struggled and I struggled and part of
doing doing work if you're going to be
an author or a painter an artist any any
any of the arts or anything particularly
writing or drawing you have to do it
alone have to go sit down alone in a
room and the work captures you the work
heats you up and makes you a better
person it challenges you and then what
you have to do what I have to do or
anybody asked though you have to break
yourself into two two parts you argue
with yourself is this the right way to
do it no it's got it's got flaws in it
is this the better way yeah that's a
better way then you start to do it and
it doesn't work and then you got to try
something else and you have to struggle
and struggle and work and work and work
and the hardest part in life if you want
to do this kind of work is you have to
learn how to correct yourself that's a
hard thing to do because we get so
wrapped up in ourselves we think we're
right all the time but sometimes you
have to get out of yourself and move
over here and say is that the right
thing to do so here to get started I eat
I had just to show you
I did all these drawings in black and
white and why they turned out in color
was when I went to well I'm getting
ahead of the story but here's here's the
first try to illustrate when in the
course of human events and I had the
five men standing around a big poster
and it says human events love trust
marriage birth parental responsibilities
growth going to school
war and peace sweat no human events keep
coming all the time and in my life I was
born in the first world war then came
this then came the depression then came
a second world war then came the Korean
War then came to Vietnamese well I've
lived through Wars and and here our
nation is talking about another war
right now so we have to we have to live
in human events so the only solution I
had was to take the five men as you'll
see in the book and each one has to
bolon coming out of their mouth and
they're talking in the first man john
adams says these are the human events
being born being loved being nurtured
when i think of that when i look at
little human babies they're so helpless
they couldn't survive unless they had
somebody taking care of them then you
grow up and you can and if you're lucky
you're blessed with good health and all
of you look healthy and then you get an
education and finally you become an
adult and then something goes wrong you
get a job and and the job doesn't work
out failure what are you gonna do you
got to pick yourself up and start all
over again and then you've got a risk
again you take chances life is taking
chances you can't play it safe and then
you're you you you find a lot finally
you find a livelihood something you'll
like like here am I
and I'm so lucky that I found a
livelihood that I loved I used to love
to go to work a lot of people are slaves
they hate their jobs and that's terrible
because we're not supposed to be slaves
it'll be free and if you can find how
find a job you like it makes your life
so much more enjoyable and I read in the
paper recently that that I think I know
what percentage but a huge percentage of
people can't wait to retire from their
jobs because they hate it I wasn't that
way I loved my job and when I saved up
enough money my wife and I we decided I
could quit and do some of this stuff
that I love to do so we went on and and
and and I began to work and I got all
steamed up and even though you work
alone you you you you finally I finished
I did the whole all that all the words
and I had a publisher who published
another book of mine and I brought the
work to the publisher thank you
brought the work to the publisher and
then once again I found this is
fascinating here was the the publisher
who would edited so many books in this
lifetime when he looked at my work it
was all done in black and white he said
you know Sam I don't remember reading
the Declaration of Independence this man
is 65 years old and that gave me hopes
that maybe they were gonna publish it
but they didn't six weeks later he
called me and said sorry we don't think
it'll work
now I'm disappointed you build your
hopes up and then I said failure I
thought I fail and I said well it's one
more hurdle I got to get over that
so I sat down and what did I do I
remembered the New York Times I said no
I'm gonna do I'm gonna make Xerox copies
of all my drawings and sent it to mr.
sells Burger the chief executive of the
New York Times and I said as long as you
do this every year you should publish a
book so that everybody can read the
Declaration of Independence that was
pretty nervy of me to do because I don't
know the man and sometimes you got to be
brave and and what could I lose at my
age so I sent it and he sent a reply
back very quickly and he said the New
York Times will not publish your work
but I am impressed I'm impressed by what
you've done I would suggest that you
find a publisher in the children's book
world so again the library came to the
rescue I went to my library and I found
a book called the literary marketplace
literary marketplace has a list of every
published in the whole world and all the
people who have different jobs in each
publishing company and scholastic has
had so many names I didn't know which
one to choose and I just went almost
blind and I put my finger down and fell
on a lady's name Barbara Marcus vice
president of sales or something and I
sent it to her and a month later a man
by the name of Kenneth right an editor
at scholastic called me on the phone and
said would you come in and speak to me
sometime when you I says I'll be right
in
and he said we're gonna publish it then
I met all these other people and I met
his assistant Alisa Jacobs then I met
Nancy sabato the art director and they
decided not I not me they decided the
books should be in color would I like to
color all the drawings that I made and I
said no I'm too tired
can you find somebody and they found a
young man Greg Papp rocky and he sat
down and and this good taste he colored
that colored all the drawings I made and
then they decided they're gonna publish
it quickly generally it takes about two
years from this time they start to
publish a book this time they did it in
I think in seven or eight months they
they worked night and day to get it out
for the last fourth of July and it got
into the bookstores they had it finished
by in June and they had it in the
bookstores by the fourth of July and so
far it has gotten good good results and
good good comment and what I learned
again see I said I have to do when I
started I had to sit alone and do what I
did then once I got into the world of
publishing the book then you have to
work with a team with a group after
everybody has to listen to everybody
else and and you discuss things and
there were drawings in here that that
I'll show you that day that they told me
when were improper this one talks about
that the the sentence was that we were
being invaded from within and
assaulted from without that and so I
made a terrible frightening drawing of
the tiger in the woods and alligators in
the water and they said it's too
frightening so I had to do it over again
that's why you see it torn out from a
page and I still like it because it's
frightening but but we had we had to
work together and and many many other
things in the same way
here's a here's a drawing that was
almost and and this is language one of
the sentences was for transporting us
beyond seas to be tried for pretended
offences that they were capturing
colonial sailors and putting him on
trial and I thought I'd have him have
one captive wrapped up in a British flag
and I he says abducted damn it
and I said you can't say damn it in the
children's book so I had to do that over
again and I did it over again by having
a whole ship you see part of his ship
you'll see it later in the end there and
so it was doing all these things over
and over again now the part that that
that is fascinating to me is when I
think of my life I've been very lucky
there's a sentence in a 10th commandment
says honor honor your father and mother
and I was most fortunate and had a
wonderful father and a wonderful mother
I was a kind of a difficult boy when I
was and you're great about sixth grade
seventh grade I I was a dreamer I didn't
know what I wanted to be I think I
wanted to be a baseball player
and anything in sports that just loved
sports yes and so when I went to high
school I was an athlete and then I began
a year at college at CCNY and I had gone
to school I up to my neck I couldn't I
didn't want to go anymore and I came
home and argued with my mother and
father and I said I can't go anymore I
have enough school I want to get out and
you want to see the America and in 1934
and the deficit the depression I argued
with my mother and and she finally said
go if you want to go but she didn't
think I would do it but I did it I
hitchhiked all across the United States
of America up and back it was a terrible
time there was a drought in the West and
I was this young 18 year old kid I
didn't know anything but I saw America
and and I became I guess realized that I
loved this country because it was kind
to me let me see it and everything was
free and open and yeah when I came back
my father said well what are you gonna
do I said I'm gonna find a job I went to
look for a job there were no jobs so my
father kindly took me under his wing he
said now tell you what he was an artist
and a photo engraving shot
he said I'll teach you what I know how
to do and then you be able to make a
living he says it's gonna take you five
years and you'll have to go to art
school at night and go to college at
night and I said I'm willing I'm willing
and he got me a job as a messenger boy
in the afternoons and then the date day
and the early part of the day he taught
me what he knew and after about three
years he said you're ready to fly then I
went out and found that I found a work
that I loved to do
and in that experience because you're
gonna be faced with this there were many
people who were discourages when I were
on with my portfolio people would look
at my work and say kid you'll never make
it and I'd walk out of their room might
be crestfallen and I'd say wait a minute
I'm only 19 years old 20 years old how
can i man tell me that what I can't do
and then I got I encouraged myself and
next guy who told me that I said you
can't tell me that I want to be that and
I'm gonna be it don't don't don't put me
down and the world is full of put her
down us the ones who you needed the lift
the rubbers the ones who give you
courage and courage and curtain and the
most encouraging one has got to be
yourself it's got to come out of you and
so my father taught me and I finally
found this work that I loved and it
earned me a splendid livelihood and I
raised a beautiful family we lived and
lived up in the Bronx and unfortunately
in the beginning of the my marriage I
was drafted believe it or not I was once
a soldier it's hard to believe even for
me and then I came back and finally we
had enough money to move out to the
suburbs and we bought a little house and
life went on and on and we had two sons
and this is a little story to share with
you because one of the things that we do
as authors are we put our personal lives
into what we do there's something about
our lives that we put in and in this
case I'll share this little personal
story because it's quite lovely this
shape I made this it got crushed as I
came it's a 12-sided shape
called the dodecahedron and back 40
years ago one of our sons made this for
his mother I don't know how he made it
he never studied art but it's paper and
toothpicks and how he built it I'll
never know
and what he did was he made a greeting
to his mother now his mother used an
expression always the expression was
mother type question you know mothers
can get be a pain in the neck when they
keep asking you did you do this did you
make your bed they did go on did you put
fold your clothes and jipang it up the
mother type questions you got mother
type questions in their house too so and
see how he made this in honor of her
because now he had grown up and it's a
very beautiful thing neat and he writes
on a dear mom this is a dodecahedron it
is for you and for your guidance and
mother type questions that have helped
to keep me on the right track I give you
my love now if you open the book to page
32
you'll see a man holding a dodecahedron
in his hand and on a dodecahedron it
says prudence prudence means be careful
be careful and so all these things that
then I that I gathered together in my
life there in the book there that I'm in
there there's part of my life
you can't yeah if you're gonna do
something like that you cannot exclude
all your surroundings all the things
that happen to you people generally
sometimes they ask me how long did it
take you to do and answer basically what
they're looking for is did it take me a
year to take me two years six months but
the answer really is it took my whole
life my whole life is in there
everything that I've ever done is in
there and so what I thought I would do
to to to help belong when when it came
to signing the Declaration or accepting
it they all the men weren't there that
day some signed it
six weeks later two months later New
York State was the last one to agree
they didn't get their instructions so
only 12 colonies agreed so anyhow the
first guy to sign let's see if I can
draw him over here I'll stand I'll get
out of the way after I draw this
this is
he used a quill
first man to sign was John Hancock and
he wrote his name and big to concede on
on the the first first signature down
there is the biggest one is John Hancock
an heir he wrote his name
and he did that and that was the first
guy to sign and then the rest of them
began to sign and finally they all sign
and then there was other signers one of
the signers was an old man he he
couldn't he needed a cane he had long
hair and shaky nose and he was so old
and shakey the war came and and his
hands shook and his name and when he
signed his name if he can look at it and
the on that declaration it was shaky
without like that and it got all blotted
and he just puts see Hopkins was his
name and any it was a little a little
shaky because he was old and decrepit so
that was another signer and all by all
by one one by one they all turned out to
sign and finally
I thought of going on and on but I know
you must have a lot of questions for me
so I thought I would do finish off with
one one little thing to tell you how I
feel about being here
hey thank you now if any of you have any
questions I'll try my best to answer
them any of you want to become artists
yes what um made you make this book what
made me yeah that's who that's a good
question what made me make the book it's
just I wanted to do it I wanted to do it
that nobody asked me to do it see ya
this stage men my age women men and
women they say they're looking towards
retirement I don't know what retirement
is I think retirement is when they put
you in the grave while you're alive you
have to keep your mind alert and I'm not
a bridge player I'm too old to play
tennis I don't like golf and I don't
like sitting around talking and I don't
have a computer and I'm I don't know
anything about the Internet
and I and I don't have a answering
machine I got one telephone and that's
all I have and the rest of the time I
used my imagination I wonder now in the
book is funny and the back page
somewhere towards the back there's a
Patrick Henry and a license plate
what page yeah there it is what Selma
page 136 now the part of what what you
all all of you can do this I was on a
vacation once up in New Hampshire and on
the license plate it says live free or
die I thought that's an unusual thing to
put on a license plate and I saw that
several years ago and then I got to this
page about freedom and that Liberty and
I thought there was a Patrick Henry made
a speech give me liberty or give me
death and I thought I could put those
two things together and it's an unusual
thing because Patrick Henry said it in
1775 and here is New Hampshire and 2002
having the same thing on the license
plate live free or die so we have to
treasure our freedom and so what what
what happens for me is to look around to
see things and put things that that
nobody would imagine to put together and
that becomes a new idea ideas are hard
to find and so that's my world and this
first book I did I did it for a very
simple reason
we used to get report cards did I still
give report cards okay
pardon today you all get good marks
Eiffel don't know yet don't know yet
well hang out we had to bring the report
cards home and my father had the most
beautiful handwriting and he'd sign it I
guess five five times for the term and I
his handwriting was just lovely he made
a big M like that
and when when he did that and they were
five of them in a row underneath
everyone exactly alike I used to feel so
proud when I bought the report card and
this is my father you look out writes
his name so when I did this book I did
this book in honor of my father and it's
the fifty-six who signed the fifty-six
who signed and each page as how they
wrote their name each one has asked rust
as and then each one had had their name
and and that was to honor my father
that's nobody told me to do this I just
wanted to do it and that's the part of
fun life that I hope all of you can get
into to to be what you want to be little
aside it's funny as I came here I had to
come on the Interborough Parkway I've
driven on that Parkway many many times
and now it's called the Jackie Robinson
highway and I thought in my life
remember I said I wanted to be a
baseball player and then after the
Second World War Jackie Robinson broke
the color barrier and got into baseball
and turn out to be a superstar and now
here I am driving here down to Brooklyn
on the Jackie Robinson Highway wonderful
so it all can happen in this country
still and your people are gonna make it
happen and so I thank you all for your
patience and for coming here and good
luck any more questions
yes you have a question yeah
wait wait wait how many books did you
write for four books this is one of them
the 56 who signed then I I was thinking
one day about what keeps America from
from internal strife a civil war and I
said good laws and I said the best law
we have is the Constitution of the
United States of America and then I I
did a book where I copied the whole
Constitution of the United States of
America all the Bill of Rights and that
got published and then this second book
I did another one was the Gettysburg
Address when I was your age we used to
have to memorize and I forgot it all
but four score and seven years ago a
country brought forth the new nation
conceived in Liberty and freedom and so
those are the four and that answer you
yes yes
my kid did you always want to write a
book did you always wanna write a book
pardon
did I write books when I was to kill no
no when I was your age when I was your
age I didn't I I didn't know what I
wanted to do sometimes it takes a little
while to find out what you want to do
and you have to take chances
but there's another word that I think is
important as a commitment a lot of
people don't make commitments they say I
think I'd like to do that and then they
run into a little disappointment and
they say I don't want to do that and
they change but to make a commitment is
the hardest thing to say that's what I'm
going to do and nobody's gonna stop me
and and that if I can give you anything
I can't give you my experience I can
only tell you that there are more
discourages in the world than there are
encourages and I think if you've got
good teachers they encourage you yes do
you use those same characters in all
your books do I want to use the same
characters in all your help no no this
this time I use different characters to
fit the scheme here's another man once
asked a question
a book no no in that regard when I stand
here I think if my father could ever be
somewhere up there and and wherever
fathers go he would feel so good to be
here with us and he would be standing
there and he would be laughing and
saying this this wild dumb kid look what
he turns out to be what it made him feel
good
yes artistic talent that you have in
this book and on page 21 you say that we
hold these trusts to be self-evident
that all men are created equal and that
they are endowed by the creator with
certain inalienable rights now I just
want to do you know the fact that on
most of these men who who passed
Constitution they were mostly slave
owners and I just want you to clarify
why do in in this book they say all men
are equal when the slaves weren't can
you clarify that well why they say all
men are equal mainstays were they
weren't yeah that's a good question
he he this young man asks there are
certain inalienable rights that all men
are created equal by their creator but
that that's not true is that right
this is that listen that they're all
created equal to clarify it there are
people who were born with a silver spoon
in their mouth they live in big houses
they they never want for food they they
have everything and there are others who
were born poor struggling so you can say
they're not equal which is apparently
what you're concerned about but what the
equal means
is when you're born
we each have a brain we each have a set
of eyes we Chad Neutrik we have life and
then by whatever the poor circumstances
so they're the terrible circumstances we
have to fight to get out of poverty and
my mother was born in a poorhouse she
never had an education she was
streetwise she grew up and she was a
family of six her father died when when
she was a little girl of ten she had to
go to work when she was twelve years old
and her words stick with me she said we
never knew we were poor because
everybody in the neighborhood was the
same and so the another another part of
I don't know if it answers your question
another important part is what we do
what some people do is compare
themselves to others I have a friend who
wanted to be an artist and in his art
class in the art school he always looked
around he said those guys and gals are
so much better they're better I'm not
good enough and that was a terrible
thing you can't compare yourself to
others you have to be content with what
you have and so I don't know whether
enhancing your question but some people
are born poor and and there's a man down
there homeless man I've been watching
him and I wonder what goes on in his
mind I have no idea but he hangs out and
he does what he needs to do his mind is
not my mind
but there's a world out there
and it's it's there because you're
created equal for you to take a good
piece of pie out of it depending on what
you want to do and I have to compliment
you because of the manner in which you
asked the question that to me if I was a
teacher I I'd I'd give you a good couple
of check marks and say this man's got
character
so I become your encourage err yes
was your father a famous illustrator no
my father was not a famous illustrator
and that is a good question my father
was a good artist but not famous he he
earned a good livelihood and one of the
things that that I find fault with
myself I never asked my father enough
questions he was a quiet man
and I was so involved with myself as
many young people are that unfortunately
he died when he was 60 years old but I
never had the time to ask him how did
you learn to be what you became I never
never took the time to ask him and just
there's a little little thing
that he taught me when when when he was
teaching me how to how to design letters
he said when when when there's a rent
when there's a straight letter like it
let's say it's an e it goes right to the
wine and right to the line now these
lines aren't parallel when they're were
round letters he taught me the round
letter if it's an S has to go a little
over the line over the line and below
the lines just to touch because
optically if it doesn't go over the line
and it only goes up to the line and it's
round it doesn't look as tall as that as
the one that touches so optically you
have to so when I remembered that just
the other day I said he must have gone
to school somebody must have taught him
that
so what I do regret as I said was that I
never took the time to ask him and now
he's gone and I'll never find out so one
of the things that I do when I visit
with my grandchildren and we sit around
the dinner table I tell him all sorts of
two stories about my life and they sit
there with their mouths open because
they can't realize that in 1924 we
didn't have a telephone in the house
what a big thing when we got our first
telephone the first telephone and now
people going around with the cell phones
and
they can't get along without a cellphone
and my mother she's a little woman about
five foot [ __ ] just over five feet we
used to have an ice box not a
refrigerator and then the building the
apartment building there was a
dumbwaiter which was a box that went on
a pulley down to the basement and up
again and when the Iceman came he yell
up the up the dumbwaiter mr. Fink how
much ice and she's down 25 cents and he
cut a chunk ah I said a cube that big
and put it on a dumbwaiter and pull it
up in this little woman would take a
towel and grab this big chunk ice and
drop it in the top of the icebox and
that would stay for a couple days and if
came the weekend there was food in there
she and she wanted to go away on Friday
afternoon she had to wait until the Ice
Man came because he didn't have ice over
the weekend the food would spoil so that
was another time and I can remember wash
our washing clothes on the top of the on
the top of the stove and a big big big
bucket a breast bucket and taking a
panel and hitting the clothes to clean
it and so there and that's all within
the short time everything has changed
changed a subway ride was a nickel a
loaf of bread was eight cents a man
would make if a man made $35 a week he
could get married and raise a family and
it was another time
was another time and and so here I am
I'm like the Ancient Mariner and so is
there anything more yes you're you're a
scholar oh this is 42 now my whole class
over yeah and someone and some of them
over there right in my school we this
woman
I just we just like to know something
you said and on page 42 a very one can
turn to page 42 right now
what's it 22 I'm 42 42 yeah yeah you see
when this picture right here you say we
will have to learn to defend ourselves
um now you mean um the Americans had to
defend themselves from the British right
yeah over their eyes I've read some
information is saying that when slaves
defended themselves it was considered as
a problem you went to slave she didn't
himself that was considered as a problem
liking their masters or whatever do you
think do you think it's right correct to
defend yourself or your slave or do you
think is negative I wanna know from your
perspective that's a good question yeah
you you really have terrific questions
and he should start teaching anyhow that
defending yourself in in terms of and
the I guess in the Bible
pardon I mean defending yourself a fine
I mean defend yourself like if you have
to defend yourself during the own and
you have to help defend others like if
you see like what happened here a couple
years ago there was a a woman was
murdered in the street or being intact
and people looked out the window and
they didn't nobody ran to help her and
that the point that was missing was
somebody should he run down to help that
lady but instead everybody sat by and
let her let her be murdered defending
yourself is important yes but anyhow
that's it's your your your a deep deep
deep follow